from yellow number five to bht here are
all the most shocking chemicals we found
in fast food chains in the uk and the us
this is food wars
over the past season and a half of food
wars we found some interesting
dare i say shocking chemicals in some of
the foods and food processes
we've created this compilation of these
moments and joe and i are going to react
to them now
sure we may not be food scientists food
experts scientists or really anything
but we do have these fancy lab coats
which i think gives us some credibility
i got mine at party city fantastic let's
dive in
[Music]
you know the only difference is that our
pepperoni contains beef
also preservatives but hydrate hydro
laziness and buddhahood blah blah bha
and bht
i can't pronounce them they're bad
it turns out bha and bht are actually
subject to restrictions in the european
union
and can't be added to foods such as
pepperoni this might be because studies
have shown that bha
can cause tumors in rats and is
therefore reasonably anticipated to be a
carcinogen in humans
you have no idea how much we spent on
those dancing rats i mean
what doesn't cause tumors and rats right
i feel like rats are always getting
cancer anyway
and they don't say the portions are they
eating human-sized portions of bha and
bht
then yeah of course they're getting
cancer oh
i'm well die doing what i love eating
banned chemicals
put in my obituary we reached out to
domino's to get some clarity on the
pepperoni situation
we got our info from their ingredients
web page however when we checked with
them they told us that their information
was incorrect
and they've updated it since to say that
bha and bht have now been removed from
the pepperoni
i think this happened at some point
during 2018 they couldn't say exactly
when
but joe sounds like you're okay after
all gotta say my hair grain is pretty
strong in this one it has nothing to do
with chemicals but uh my stuff was just
my hair's locked in on this one buddy i
loved bha and bht because this was kind
of the first episode of food wars where
we found a chemical that actually was
kind of banned and very dangerous and
didn't appear in the uk
let me straight up the european union
sounds kind of like a buzzkill
right is that what brexit was all about
we want bha and bht in our food we're
out of here
and in the u.s our donut is made up of
enriched wheat flour
and bht ah yes our old friend bht
aka butahitolated hydroxytuline
it is banned in the european union the
international agency for research on
cancer
suggests might i say strongly suggest
there is sufficient
evidence that bht causes tumor growth in
lab animals i'll tell you straight up
those donuts can be made
of dead cancer rats i'd still eat them
they're that good who cares what's in
these donuts
also according to webmd bht is also used
to treat
genital herpes that's right
i want you to think about that every
time you bite into a krispy kreme
genital herpes and every time you get
genital herpes
i want you to think of krispy kreme i
want those two things together in your
mind for the rest of your life
you are welcome
try calcium phosphates dymonium
phosphate and that last guy dymonium
phosphate aka dap not the sequel to wap
what does that stand for it is also used
as a fertilizer and
as a fire retardant so when we have the
next wildfire outbreaks in the state
because it definitely will happen we're
going to start dropping krispy kremes on
those wildfires
solved
[Music]
one thing we need to note about the us
taco bell menu is that items like the
baja blast
and the doritos tacos locos i think the
shells
have an ingredient called yellow number
five
yellow number five is not in the uk of
course it's in the u.s
in the uk you usually find yellow five
referred to as tetrazine
it's on a list of six chemicals which
when added to food must contain the
following warning
may have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children
teletrazine is a fascinating one because
it's in so many places in america and
basically nowhere here
but honestly like in things like the
baja blast i don't think that's what's
causing the hyperactivity i think it's
the million tons of sugar that they have
as a medical professional uh you're not
going to taco bell
because you're concerned about what's
going in your body you're going to taco
bell
because you don't care what's going in
or out of your body apparently
in some cases it causes itching and
hives and people
who eat it disgusting
itching and hives yup that's fine i feel
most people eat that food already had
itching and hive issues anyway so if
it's not coming from the taco belt
coming from i don't know sleeping on
unwashed bed sheets
hey i ate it growing up and i'm
perfectly fine i should note that i have
a full head of gray hair and i just
turned 23.
what's up there are a few things to
watch out for on the menu at five guys
yeah like the hat guys for example the
pickles in the u.s
in the u.s the pickles contain a food
coloring called yellow five or
tetrazine if this is added to foods in
the european union
my hair looks stupid in the five minutes
episode why did nobody warn me
there is one thing to look out for on
the menu if you're in the us and you get
a salad
the croutons contain azodicarbonamide or
ada
this is a substance that's usually used
to make vinyl foam plastics which form
things like yoga mats
it's actually been banned from use in
food in the uk since the 1990s
so this is my comment on that yoga mat
thing
it's always something even we're trying
to be healthy a salad has yoga mat
plastic and it's ridiculous like
why do our croutons have plastic in them
just get regular croutons without
plastic it doesn't make any sense
oh my god i want pizza hut so bad right
now i know it's weird to stick up for a
chemical but i want to point out that to
my understanding again i've done
no research on this it's not like
they're making the yoga mats
and then taking the chemicals out of the
yoga mats if you imagine the chemical
like
one truckload goes to the yoga mat
factory and the other truckload goes to
pizza hut
i'm assuming right or are they recycling
yoga mats
if they're doing that then never mind
that's really gross
the only ingredient in the u.s chipotle
that gave me a bit of pause was
something called
gypsum gypsum is also known as calcium
sulfate
hydrate right okay and chipotle uses
that in their tofu
process when they separate the chunks
from the liquid gypsum is also found in
drywall
chalk and shampoo of course it is now
does the gypsum
stay in the tofu or is it just used for
the separating purposes
i don't care i'm never getting tofu from
chipotle
don't worry about gypsum it's fine you
know the other there's billboards for um
like every other no yeah yeah yeah like
just just just this and then next is
gypsum don't worry about it
you're fine
one piece of information you can get
from the uk's faq page is that the
plant-based
great imitator wrap might not actually
be as plant-based as it seems
the baste and the tortilla wrap used
both contain shellac now shellac is also
sometimes called confectioner's glaze
and it's a natural polymer that's used
to
give things a waxy finish and to trap in
moisture love the shirt i wore in the
nando's episode what's your favorite
harry shirt so far
leave a comment below but where does
sherlock actually come from
well it's actually secreted by female
lack beetles onto trees
in india and thailand this means it's
technically an animal product and
although it can be gathered without
harming the beatles this is hard to
achieve in practice
not nice sherlock was one which popped
out to me when i was reading the
ingredients list just because
the usual context i've had it in is like
gel nails
so as soon as i kind of knew that it was
in that i wanted to do some more
research into it and it turns out it's a
beetle thing who knew
however after combing through their
ingredients list in the uk and the us we
did find one or two things to look out
for
for example caramel color it's used in a
range of prep products from the
dressing that they put on their salad to
the caramel syrups which they put into
their drinks
well in the u.s you'll find caramel
color in the salted caramel hot
chocolate and the salted caramel latte
which i drink caramel color is worth
pointing out because it's on the state
of california's proposition 65 list of
chemicals which are known to the state
to cause cancer or reproductive toxicity
oh reproductive toxicity that's fun
see i was scared but the good news is
there's only two types of caramel color
classes three and four that contain the
chemical that's the blame for this
for mel the bad news is that class 4
caramel color does appear on the menu in
the uk
while there is some evidence to suggest
that the amounts currently in our food
are pretty safe
the state of california banning it isn't
a great look
at a federal level the fda still says
that there is
no reason to believe that there are any
immediate or short-term health risks
presented by 4mel
at the levels expected in food so
kind of up to you whenever we reach out
to someone about something like caramel
color the answer tends to be along the
lines of
well you know at its current level it's
fine but surely if there's something
which has
a dangerous level then just get rid of
it all together it can't make that much
of a difference
come on guys
the one other thing worth pointing out
is the difference between the wraps used
in the two countries
there's only one wrap used in the uk and
it's this one a kibbled rye wrap here's
the ingredients list
we also have kibbled rye wraps in the
u.s and the ingredients less is
virtually identical
but we can also get a plain tortilla
wrap as part of the falafel and red
peppers and pretz chicken part wraps
the ingredients list for this wrap is a
little more alarming
there's three different gums in here but
it's actually the fumaric acid you may
want to watch out for
it's an acidity regulator that's pretty
common in tortillas
but the european union says that while
it's practically non-toxic
long-term exposure is probably toxic to
your kidneys
due to the results of studies carried
out on calves and rats
a nice non-answer like i'm not saying
it's not but we're also not saying that
it is
long-term effect kidney damage i'm not
worried about it
again dr joe says probably fine and then
and that billboard i have a cigarette in
my mouth
[Music]
what we can get is a list of allergens
and it has a couple of fun things to
note
for example there is a significant risk
of there being traces of seafood in our
banoffee concrete
do you say banana banafi i've been more
worried about that the health of banafi
and there are also sulphites in our
chicken bites and in the shack sauce
we may or may not also have shellfish in
our shroom burger
shack burger shack stack and smoke shack
so there's no potential seafood the uk
equivalents of these burgers have no
idea why there might be shellfish in
ours here in the u.s i i couldn't even
guess why still not being explained to
me why there is a significant risk
there could be seafood in a milkshake
because obviously that's not something
that goes together
i do not want a shrimpy milkshake no
thank you
while we might have an ingredients list
for our bread we do know that it's
likely to not be perfect
for example an irish court recently
declared that subway cannot call its
loaves bread
due to the high sugar content subway
uses more than 10
sugar in their flour how about they
can't call their sandwiches sandwiches
because they're too gross
the high percentage amount of their food
tasting bad is the reason it cannot be
called
sandwiches or edible food so i actually
reached out to subway about their bread
issue and we did get a response from
them the official subway line on this is
subway's bread is of course bread we've
been baking fresh bread in our stores
for more than three decades
and our guests return each day for
sandwiches made on bread that smells as
good as it tastes
so they're sticking with their guns
island disagrees whose side are you on
[Music]
it's worth pointing out one other faq
from the uk page which is that the uk
nandos have explicitly committed to
never using
chlorinated chicken from america
chlorinated chicken's been in the
headlines a lot recently because it's
kind of become the face
of differing food standards between the
uk and the us it refers to the process
of giving slaughter chickens a chemical
wash before they're packaged and sent to
consumers
what do you guys have against our
chlorinated chicken
jake joking you're gonna see oh there's
so many things against our chlorine
this is done to kill harmful bacteria
like salmonella
even the european union admits that it's
unlikely to pose any health risks to
consumers
but campaigners say that it also allows
farmers to cover up lower production
standards throughout the chicken rearing
process
the good news is that it's estimated
only 10
of us chicken actually gets treated with
chlorine
so it's not a guarantee that nando's
chicken in the us will have been through
the process
but it's an interesting example of the
different food standards in the uk
and the us i'm perfectly fine with that
right
i'm perfectly fine with that yeah clean
the raw chicken i mean would you rather
have
salmonella get out of here like it's
fine i have never gotten salmonella
from what i hear it's pretty awful trust
me
i am a diarrhea expert and it sounds
unbearable give me a chlorinated dipping
sauce
with those with those chicken tenders
i'm perfectly fine with that
i am not fine with risking salmonella
it's fine quipping a baby
that's my third billboard
[Laughter]
cops are coming you hear that
they're coming for your medical license
oh [ __ ]
i can write as many prescriptions as i
can before they take it away